oh hello and welcome to this video
playing how well so is that no name ok I
recently had a fun game with a panko
tray to try it again it's not an easy
opening to play oh this is a tough line
it's a very tough line yeah and promise
that here you have problems with
standard ideas and I don't know the
specifics of the e6 variation which is
probably best yeah yeah this is not a
super great line for black keep it at
least it's not so highly tactical as as
a success which I really feel I cannot
play without a specific knowledge so
we'll see what happens here why it is
probably a bit better him a bishop a 5
might be an issue at some point hmm
anyway this I have to do yeah now white
looks better him but as it's a very
difficult line for someone like me oh
it's not an expert or pin in this
opening ok
after f3e six is best but this leads to
completely irrational complications that
I really don't feel up to playing
without anything without any specific
knowledge okay here it's got might be
five I guess doesn't look good Bishop
here it doesn't have a discovery okay
it's good to play a force a thing no
it's not going to play for a cannon I
don't mind this that much so now okay I
had to give up the bishop pair of it not
sure how important that is I'd be six
I'm not sure I'd I try night FD seven
eyes planes super quickly probably it's
got some experience with this or I don't
know might be fire crew Queen their legs
makes some sense but ok oops what the
heck hey a damn windows 10 update should
really switch that off so now it's it's
damn annoying okay so what's this so he
invites a repetition with okay I can do
this first why not and see if you just
wants to draw be a bit lame thing quite
probably is a bit better but maybe never
right here it's difficult for him to not
play Queenie five I guess ok so if I
take this call is probably going to be
somewhat dangerous ok so it's there a
different um approach I don't have a
tactic ticking looks immensely dangerous
you should be six and six seven coming
up yeah probably queencess six is a
strong move yeah it is a strong
well okay
Quincy six was good I have it takes
about the porn i think i'm somewhat okay
okay here hmm nice got the check and see
aight jack ok I've got c4 check and
possibly 95 95 and then the check maybe
yeah I can just take this if I want
maybe I showed him c3 is attacked I also
have the check but i think i'll i'll
take this may be equal or something no
I'm actually better here I'm actually
better in this position because of text
access Queenie one checkmate yeah it
takes is 7p so you have some miracle
draw maybe he has but I have check on d4
right check on d4 King everyone Queen B
five chick and this is that winning okay
I can also take the bishop Queen f7 this
is going to be a draw unfortunately for
here okay I can also check here but
let's try this
let's try this King f1 is the lady
resigns I'm obviously too stupid to see
why this one's I can't have continued
one okay actually yeah I've couldn t 1
okay so King King yet I can also take
now yeah a sorceress is also winning
Jack I can go here so probably just take
Adam check and here I'm not getting
mated it's funny I mean okay i can i can
just play Bishop g7 but the engine wants
to just move up the board yeah it's a
very lucky win actually I was worse the
whole game yeah the thing is f3 is one
of those very hard-hitting lines and if
you don't know it you're worse esox is
the best move I think that's what theory
has established after some years I know
that this is father this is the way it
is played there's this and yeah I'm not
sure how it how it continues it's a
super super sharp but here the theory
only starts oh yeah this is the casual
kind of stuff that white ones yeah I
think it's just better human 92 93 m
that is all looking normal yeah white is
slightly better him but I mean it's
probably not super bad or anything for
me but it's more comfortable for him
okay um maybe 95 Maria the engine wants
to do this and then see for now k I also
have this which I didn't really
appreciate that much mmm no Nets that's
probably okay this is what the computer
gives there and I have this this mean
yeah this is probably okay engines has
equal so then Knight b6 is probably
wrong but
my experience is really limited in those
open in this opening so I tried one
repetition and now you went here yeah
this is this was uncomfortable to meet
when taking i think is downright bad i
have a hard time here with with those
two points supported especially by this
so i cannot do this so i went here when
will be one it's funny okay this is not
this is not working the computer still
likes my position after this move which
didn't occur to me it wants to play c4
okay King f1 strange but maybe pamir
maybe it didn't make some sense computer
wants to do this and understand maybe
something here for the background makes
sense okay it's not easy for why them if
he does that I'm going to take if 5 i'm
going to take and so not quite clear how
he goes ahead from here and this is an
idea huh so I I didn't really see the
position correctly i was thinking i was
in trouble but I wasn't but I could have
been in trouble here if he takes on ba j
Queen takes Queen B father's where the
engine just has white wins yeah maybe
the bond is too strong him like this and
this possible yeah the computer gets
plus to hit is a win then the day point
is too strong it he played this move
instead takes and this is wrong Queen
takes is a person lot stronger uh-huh
it's essentially the same position
probably as be formed check I would have
thought that maybe there is some kind of
player but computer doesn't
yeah I cannot move the night's hmm I
mean okay i can go here but it's
probably not leading to much computer
gives this it's all not that easy to do
but yeah it seems to be clearly better
Queen a six or so good now and a five
yeah if I vista blunder quite quite
clearly King f1 is given by the engine
and why should win probably because now
the a porn is by far too strong yeah it
was a real blunder so I just took it and
yeah now he has to avoid this which
loses immediately the the big problem is
that after this and this it cannot take
because this is a made in one and I had
the way it check turned out I was just
winning even though it took me ages to
to grasp I was actually intending this
move Queen be one at his King it to win
this is not it seems to win as well but
I of course I can't just take I can just
take the bishop and check also for
simply this reason yeah done not just
hear the king is save and the Seaport
we'll just do do his job okay tough game
thanks for watching